i really much focused on getting things
done i think that i took
every opportunity to execute on
something
as if it was the biggest thing for the
company
[Music]
karen fanan thank you for joining on 20
minute leaders how are you
i'm great thank you how are you
fantastic are you calling from israel
right now
yes yes i'm in israel today wonderful
well i'm i'm in israel as well and it's
it's great to have you on this show
because i i am very excited to talk to
you about
your position and yet and not just your
position as chief commercial officer
at get and one of israel one of them you
know the
israel's proudest companies a a unicorn
within israel
and that probably every israeli uses if
not on a daily basis at least on a
weekly basis
but i believe that it's branched to be
much greater than just israel at this
point
uh you'll tell us more about that but
really your journey within get
and your journey as an entrepreneur as
you as you mentioned
previously i think will be fascinating
but we have to start all the way from
the beginning from
cotopaxi
what happened and what prompted me to
climb the largest volcano
so uh yeah that's a good question um i
mean i was always a big fan of
you know doing um of extreme
right so bungee jumping and and jumping
from a plane and i
you know when i traveled in israel it's
quite common that when you
finish the army you usually go and
travel for a few good months
so i did my trip um at south america
and when i got to ecuador um i was told
that there is the
you know highest active volcano that if
you want you can climb
um and it's as simple as that you don't
need to prepare you don't need to do
anything you just
need to register obviously it was
extremely difficult
it's like 19 000 feet right like 5 000
more than 5 000 meters tall right
yeah like you don't climb everything you
can do a part of the road
by a car and then in order to climb to
the cliff
you have to wake up at something like 12
a.m
because you know it's it's freezing
there so you really need to
to kind of wake up when it's um night
time
and then you have special equipment and
you start to climb and by
you know the sunrise you get to the top
you get to see the sunrise and then you
have to go
all the way down so it was really kind
of once in a lifetime experience
um yeah i'm sure i have to say that i
can relate to
pretty close to what you're saying i
didn't climb cotopaxia i climbed
kilimanjaro about a year and a half ago
with my family
and we had to wake up at midnight and
climb during the night so that we have
better footing
on the on the frozen uh on the frozen
hill
and it's probably one of the most
difficult things i've ever done but that
reward of getting up there we actually
missed the sunrise by a few minutes
so we have to do it again but yeah
it's remarkable karen what is it what is
the responsibility of a chief commercial
officer at a company like
get so obviously
like commercial or revenue
responsibility
um may be a little bit different between
companies so at get
um the responsibility includes to drive
the revenue from our core business units
one of our main business units at gatt
is the b2b
activity which we've recently developed
into a more of a global sas
product so as chief commercial i'm
actually managing all of the
sales organization as well as the
account management
but also the marketing activity um
and i'm also you know overlooking the
acquisition and retention in our
consumer business so
basically everything that generates
revenue to the company sits within
the commercial unit it sounds a little
bit important
from what i'm gathering a little bit you
know money money is important
in most cases but karen uh you know most
of us
know get as a b2c product i'm ordering
it through the
through my app and i go down there what
is the what is a b2b initiative
of a ride sharing company like that yeah
that's a great
that's a great question because get is
indeed known for being a consumer
company because that's how it was
kind of born um but not many people know
that
right after the launch of the consumer
service get also launched a b2b
service for corporations and basically
developed a technology that helps
companies to manage their
taxi rights for their employees so for
example if you work for a company
that you know and you need to travel
quite a lot
um for work purposes so if in the past
you had to go
you know take a taxi keep the receipt
and then reimburse it then
and expense it then today
by using the get platform you don't
really need to do it because everything
is managed by the get system
and all you have to do is just to kind
of you know switch to the business
profile
book a taxi um and that's it it's as
simple as that
and what we've lately also been doing
is to take the same platform globally
by integrating into the local providers
so we started by announcing a
partnership with lyft in the us
because get uh you know do not operate
in the u.s
um but also with ola in london and kerry
international which is a large show
first service
and so on and so forth we keep on
integrating into many many providers so
slowly we're kind of creating
a global ecosystem of all of the
existing providers the consumer
providers that we all know
and we make it more accessible for
business purposes
it sounds complicated exciting and
pretty innovative
to to for a company that whether it was
a consumer-centric up until now but but
but you're when you're adapting to the
to the emerging needs obviously of all
the
these different corporations but karen
you have it and even even more unique to
what you're doing is the journey of how
you got there so
starting at entry level so before that
you spent two years at atm t
technical project manager now and then
moved into r
d product management how does that work
entering a company like get as an entry
level and making your way
to sea level with internally talk a
little bit about the process and the
challenges that go with that
i'd love to so so first of all i think
it was
it was um i would divide it to two kind
of major
transitions right the first one was the
fact that i moved from
um you know r d and tech organizations
into operations because when i joined
get
i joined as a marketing operations
manager which pretty much means that you
need to
execute all of the global marketing
projects before that my
you know my experience was was solely
based on
r d and technology and and releasing new
uh versions um to become live and deploy
new versions
so that change was was quite massive
because it's completely different
language
different pace um and and that was great
i think get has given me the opportunity
to move from
tech to operations without any
experience in marketing because they
believe
in in general it's a company that
believes that if you have the skill set
and the motivation
you do not necessarily need to have the
super specific relevant experience
which i really believe in that because i
think that when
people bring their different experiences
uh from different roles and different
departments they actually create
something very much
unique and and you know diverse rather
than just kind of
you know doing all the same over and
over again
so i joined get um as marketing
operations manager
which is you know as mentioned an
entry-level position
um and since then i started a
like a crazy journey or a roller coaster
if you want to call it
i think that there were several things
that that helped me in that journey
first of all
i really much focused on getting things
done i think that i took
every opportunity to execute on
something um
as if it was the biggest thing for the
company looking back
i know that many of the things that i've
done at the beginning were not that
important
but you know if we were talking five and
a half years ago you would hear me
talking about it as if that is going to
change the face of the company you know
so
i love that yeah and i think that
you know it's a part of the thing
because when you kind of approach
something
as if it it's the most important thing
and
and you execute it in the best possible
way which means that
if someone's asked you to do this you
will do something
here right like way beyond think out out
of the box
um and most importantly execute right
um that is a critical thing and i was
lucky enough also to again to work in a
company that
embrace innovation and embrace execution
so you know when my manager saw that
you know i'm capable of executing that
he gave me more challenges so
the next challenge that i got was to
launch a brand new
idea that get had it was right at the
time that get
changed its name from get taxi to get
and they had this crazy idea that get
can get you anything
so you can get pizza on demand flowers
on demand
a courier on demand to do deliveries for
you
and my manager asked me you know if you
want to launch it again it's not it
you know it sounds big it was just me
doing everything
seeing what we can do um and that's how
i started
you know that was the first step in in
launching the first startup within
startup we started by launching
verticals at get
different products that you can get on
demand
um and i remember you know we had to do
everything
right like engage with couriers we
wanted to
to register them so we went and
downloaded like a freemium
you know uh form online and ask the
couriers to use the
the free form um to register
and then we brought them in to do some
kind of um
you know training sessions yeah how to
use the
the app so you actually have to do
everything
exactly like building a startup in your
own device
right it just did you do it within an
already operating company
um obviously you can leverage some of
the tools that exist but in most cases
you really have to do everything
as if it's the first time for the
company um
and so i i've been doing that for
several months after
several months i think i i
i had to learn uh one of the greatest
kind of lessons
which was to to decide what we do not do
we started to do all of these kind of
crazy pizza sushi stuff in 10 minutes
um but we had to acknowledge that
you know not all of these kind of
channels or services actually work
um and the only thing that actually was
well adopted by the con
by the market in israel but also in
other markets was the courier service
so back then so we decided to kind of
shut down all of the products on demand
um because getting flowers in 10 minutes
is
cool but you know many people will pay a
little bit more to get
the specific bouquet that they want even
if they need to wait three hours right
so
interesting that's an interesting uh
interesting behavior observation
and at first i i before you continue to
have to say thank you because i
am probably one of the biggest uh users
of get delivery
in my day-to-day life it completely
changed the way i think about logistics
and and i think that especially for you
know
for people that are that are busy and
they have stuff to do
one of the things that has been
fascinating for me over this past decade
or so is the num is the amount of tools
that are at our disposal to make our
days more efficient
and all of a sudden you know 10 years
ago if you were to ask somebody
if they have an alternative to go to the
store or drive 20 minutes to the flower
store
to pick up something and bring it back
there was no
there was no dilemma you have to do it
now with the introduction of good
delivery and other services
the whole consumer mindset has shifted
and i really think that
get delivery had a pivotal world a role
in educating the market on that
educating consumer behavior you educated
me into thinking
more critically about what what can i
use technology for in my day-to-day life
and what not so thank you karen
and i'm and i'm already so happy that we
got to meet so i just want to say thank
you
i'm happy to hear there's nothing that
makes me happier than
you know hearing people saying how you
know how they like the service
um obviously i use it a lot as well but
yes i agree i think that get delivery
kind of
you know brings the the importance of of
our time right if we can save time and
use technology
to do stuff for us um that's amazing and
i think it's something that in the past
you know it did not exist um at all
um most stores
most small businesses don't have
delivery service so you're actually open
not opening up a whole market
because if i now need to get some
plumbing equipment
from a few streets away then uh the only
way before was to go physically
developed but please continue with your
journey
right um yes so
um so back to get delivery so back then
we had to decide
like i had to decide you know to shut
down some of the activities it's never
a fun decision to decide that but i
think that it was another kind of step
in the journey to
to prove um again to the company that uh
you know that i'm capable you know in
the same way that i'm capable of taking
new stuff and trying them
it's also okay to come and say look this
thing doesn't work this thing works
better
let's double down on what works um
so um yeah so we we invested more and
get delivery we expanded the service
um at this time i was also promoted to
lead
get delivery globally also in the uk and
in russia
so for the first time in my life i had
to you know manage
teams abroad and hire people in
different countries different cultures
different languages
um which was another critical step
um what that what was the hardest part
about
shutting down some products so taking
that ownership and
what i'm hearing in between the lines
here is that this was also kind of a
pivotal role in your career
as you're not just this entrepreneur
that is excited and growing things and
saying yeah
like let's just run but you're also
taking that accountability and that
leadership ownership
over things that aren't necessarily
working and saying to the company listen
this
is my initiative some worked some didn't
but i'm taking accountability and and i
want us to succeed so we have to be
honest and be intentional with what
we're doing
right look so first of all again um i
was fortunate to have
a manager who is also a you know a
mentor and a coach
it's you know dave wiser the co-founder
of get he was my direct manager for the
past
five and a half years so obviously a lot
of the things were things that he kind
of challenged me to think
on whether i could be more successful
focusing on what works
and and in general in get is something
that we do quite a lot is to look at the
data
look at the numbers and enforce
ourselves to kind of really think what
business decisions we need to take based
on this data
now i'm not saying that everything has
to be um you know
solely based on data you always have to
bring also your own point of view and
and obviously i'm also a firm believer
that even intuition has something to do
with it
but when you have clear facts and you
look at the numbers
you know um it makes it makes it easier
by the way
shutting down the the ventures wasn't
the most difficult thing
like later on in my career we launched
more um you know ventures and we had to
close them as well and i'm talking about
units that got to be
you know something like 30 people
working on it so
yeah so it it happens right if you allow
yourself
to be innovative to you know try new
things
you just have to take into consideration
that some things
works you know amazingly well but some
just don't and if and if it doesn't work
then you better you know shut it down
and move on otherwise it would just kind
of drag you
pretty much drag you down um 100
now obviously you're an incredible
entrepreneur and you made an
intentional decision to be an
entrepreneur within an organization
like get and so you founded these
startups within the larger organization
of get
and obviously it must have crossed your
mind saying like you know if i'm
starting new startups here maybe like
you know i could just start a startup on
my own
and be an entrepreneur there what was
your what was your thinking
and why did you decide to do it within a
larger company
so that's a great question because you
know it took me a very long time
to be able to say it very kind of openly
because i do consider myself as
entrepreneur
um to come and say you know i
believe that i bring a better version of
myself
by being an entrepreneur because i need
um you know the environment that allows
me to be innovative
rather than starting something from
scratch now i'm not saying that in five
years from today i may find myself
you know starting my own startup from
scratch
but you know the understanding that
you can be an entrepreneur inside
a company was something that for me was
a great revolution and and i
would love to share it because i think
that there are many people that from one
hand
they feel this urge inside of them of
doing new things and thinking outside of
the box
and not just to come and be you know
another person in a
big or small company but to do something
unique but on the other hand they don't
feel
ready or they don't feel that what they
want is to start
something from scratch and they don't
feel also that they want to
join a company of three people because
they need something more stable
and the fact that you can actually
be you know what i call entrepreneur
and and and by the way in my mind the
definition of entrepreneur
is you know working for a company
building stuff and acting as if you are
the owner
so you don't see yourself as another
employee you see yourself as the owner
you see yourself
in the same way as the founder sees
himself or herself
and and that's how you kind of operate
you you
think in the same way that the the
founder will think
um it's just that you work for a company
and the thing is that
for the founder this type of people the
entrepreneurs they're the best kind of
employees right because any founder
would want
her his team to be you know of people
that
sees the company as if it was their own
um
i love it and to me it was a great
kind of just a great understanding
that you know i can feel comfortable you
know bringing my
entrepreneurship air area i would call
it just to be inside a company
um rather than you know just building
something
uh of my own i think that's inspiring
and that's a message
that a lot of people i think need to
hear right now there is i think
an understanding or or this or this
motivation by a lot of people that say
okay if you want to be innovative and
create something and
be an entrepreneur you need to leave
your you need to leave the comfortable
company
that you love perhaps and the people
that you work with that you love
and you have to go on this lonely route
of being an entrepreneur and that's not
necessarily the case
and i was just talking with the chief
revenue officer of hippo
where i work and we were talking late
last night of all the different
initiatives
and he just got so excited by all these
different startups that we're about to
start within
within the company and he said you know
it's it's you know there's no reason to
if you want to be an entrepreneur you
don't have to go and be on this lone
soldier
out there creating your thing you can
also do it within the community of a
very supportive company with the
resources of the company
and still have a huge impact and be an
entrepreneur
which is just a phenomenal karen i want
to really thank you i really want to
thank you for being so generous with
your time i know how busy you are
and i really appreciate that and before
we leave i have to ask you for three
words
that you would use to describe yourself
okay um yeah so that was a tough one
um the hardest one yes i think that i
would go with
find your passion um
because one of the things that i've
learned you know during my career
uh comparing also the different roles
that that you know
that i got to do during the years is
that
when you're passionate about what you're
doing it's like you're a different
person
you know nothing is difficult enough
nothing is hard enough everything is
possible
when you're not passionate you know
everything becomes
not everything but things become a
hustle things become more difficult
um everything becomes confusing and
and it's you know it's possible to find
your passion it took me
i think five or six years before i
really got this feeling of of saying wow
i'm
i i'm so passionate about what i'm doing
i cannot get enough of it
um so that's that's yeah that's my
channel
thank you very very much thank you and
continue doing amazing amazing things
for get for israel
for me as a consumer and for businesses
as consumers
and stay safe and stay healthy thank you
you too thank you very much